Hello?
Hi, Amanda.
How's it going?
Great!
You know what?
I'm looking at the map of Korea right now.
Really? What part of Korea are you looking at now?
Of course, Seoul.
It's the biggest city in Korea, isn't it?
Yeah, what part of Seoul would you like to visit?
Insa-dong seems attractive.
That's a perfect place!
You can find all kinds of traditional stuff there.
That's great.
I always wanted to show my family some unique, traditional stuff.
Insa-dong will be the best place to get souvenirs.
How can I get there from Jamsil subway station?
Take subway line number two, green line.
Transfer at City Hall to line number three, orange line.
Hold on, let me write it down.
You get off at An-gook station.
Is Insa-dong near there?
Yes, it takes ten minutes on foot.
Take exit number two and go straight.
The street will lead you to Insa-dong.
Okay, I got it.
Thanks for the directions.
You are welcome.